today is your lucky day the champ
uploaded a new video and you found it
I'm joking it's your lucky day because
Islam net is establishing a mega Masjid
and dawa Center and you have a unique
opportunity to be a part of that so
click the link below and donate
now how are you guys doing I'm here in
the center that you guys have funded yes
you guys have funded it mallah the Islam
net Center I'm here with Sheik zishan
how are you doing
ald I want to introduce you to the
people because I was very very impressed
with this man I met him he spent 10
years in combination in both Egypt and
Medina he's done his ba there and in
Shar and he's also completed an ma uh
in in fact he was uh studying uh sa
wasn't it yeah my thesis
was fantastic and now he's doing his PhD
on as well and what I found really
interesting is that when I was having
Nash and discussion with this particular
she he was first of all so brilliant in
terms of I'm not just doing this to you
you know sorry overpraising everybody
but in terms of using something called
which is this research tool and a Masa
came up which we're going to speak about
today um which is the masal of hitting
in the face now this is usually the
thing that is used if you look at fatwas
for example on boxing and on MMA which
has become a very it's one of the most
of asked questions I get which is a
question of course and I usually say you
know there's fat out there but I can't
do of f that's not really my
remit that I get asked about MMA and
boxing and these kinds of things and the
whole thing hinges on one Hadith and
there's different Reas of it of course
but the Hadith
is
right so it's this Hadith is effectively
saying if one of you engages in fighting
with his brother then let him um avoid
the face or let him not hit the face
because Allah has created Adam on his
image and most Scholars say on Adam's
image now this is the Hadith it's in
bukari it's in other collections as well
and if you see any of the fatwas
relating to MMA or boxing or kickboxing
or Muay Thai or any of the they kind of
all rely on this Hadith so we did a bit
of research I mean let's be honest you
did a bit of
research yeah oh no no no let us be
honest you made me do a and then you
came to me Time After Time like I think
you been there for a few days now you
come to me like 10 times did you did you
check it out you find you find anything
you find any
more but we did find ques though didn't
we because the thing the Box standard
idea is this is that there is that's
what I've seen on Islam QA and Islam I
don't know web and these kind of things
there is
that or hitting the face is in any
situation Muslim no muslim there's no n
no
it's but would you say that's an an
accurate assessment of the scholarly
tradition first of all B um I started
researching this Mas actually before you
came while I was in Madina really
because I started doing I wanted to do
some Mars myself of getting Subhan Allah
by being there I was feeling like my
health is declining and stuff like that
being there just eating the fast and all
this so I started so started doing some
stuff myself alhamdulillah um so I was
interested in finding this thing out
because I knew about let's walk and talk
come I knew about the mentioned in all
the the Contemporary they you find
online you find on the internet yes so I
took this Hadith I started researching
this Hadith I went through many many
explanations of this Hadith more than
100 maybe even 200 wow wow to see what
the classical skulls actually mention
and if it is actually the case that
there is an meaning an agreement
agreement agreement of schol exactly
about this Hadith or if there might be
room to interpret this in certain
specific context or if there are some
exceptions on this and that because so
what I did yeah because I was going to
say like I mean you you'll see heavy
weights there's no doubt about it people
likei people like people like and others
they they do believe that hating in the
face they do believe and others they
they do actually take this to mean in
all cases in all times but what did you
find which was contrary yes so you
definitely have that opinion and this is
what is crucial yes when we as academics
and that's why we are we Muslim
academics yes we need to approach uh
these kind of M first and foremost in
the academic manner sure meaning this is
not about meaning about preferring one
opinion over the other or declaring one
opinion to be strong or correct or wrong
or any anything like we're not trying to
do analyzing right and if we need to be
honest and approach
all the opinions hang and then let the
scholars decide in which situation
should be applicable and
whatever still here just make sure that
you donate by clicking the link below
cuz the rewards are unimaginable go
ahead so what you do find is that some
of the
scholars uh like for example sure he did
mention that this Hadith is in the
context of strike
this yeah the other re from Muslim that
said that
says that this is applicable if you are
fighting a
non-muslim uh meaning no no sorry sorry
Muslim yeah a Muslim meaning it does not
apply if you're fighting a Muslim a non
Muslim non Muslim flipping up the words
back because he's saying what here
brother is brother in faith he's not
saying brother in humanity yeah and
that's the other opinion yes so the
other Scholars they did say this is
referring to brother in humanity but
that's not the only opinion right so
this other opinion and other and some
other Scholars as well is that this
means brother in faith meaning if you
are finding someone who's not a brother
in faith then it does not apply okay can
we actually bring those opinions out
because someone's going to say you have
misunderstood what says if you go and
look at you know this particular call of
he's talking clearly salum brother he's
talking clearly he's getting excited
because you see the Trap that's
something El that's no problem that's a
very natural reaction let's walk a
little bit maybe yeah going
to but I was going to say that he's
going to say look he's talking about in
the in the context of War for example
he's not talking about so I did look so
a lot of these quotes are in the context
of War that's true but at the same time
I didn't find any other the scholars
maybe like one or two and even that was
unclear yeah of which you could
understand that this is restricted to
the context of warfare so let's let's so
you had many so the schs talked about
this they talked about context such as
Warfare definitely such as punishments
like even those kind of context and as
well and other kinds of context is what
is is disciplining yeah anything like
that disciplining
people in fact the opposite yeah go
ahead yeah so for example uh he
mentions
he mentioned the if one of you are
fighting then basically abstain from
heing the face right so he's saying that
this he mentions examples
he or something what does he say when he
says seems like he's talking about
Muslims when he
says that's what we referring to so what
she saying if doesn't apply yeah he says
that he says that so the counter
argument someone could possibly make is
that this is of warfare specifically but
in his other
books from his other
book he does mention that this he
mentions theith okay and then he
mentions so he mentioned these examples
and then he mentions
also as mentioned this arm is General to
every kind of
hearing
or fighting Warfare anything so the same
the same the same generalities and the
same exceptionalities would yeah exactly
exactly okay okay well someone's going
to say all du respect is not aab yes
let's just he's not he doesn't represent
a maab he's U he's a wild card in the
scholarly tradition why why don't you
bring us someone from the M have you got
anyone from M yeah you have SCH for the
as well you can say yeah he was like
that like kind of special in that kind
of sense being y
this and that right so uh for example
you have Al Ian in front of me a hanol
scholar so he was basically criticizing
this idea because you know some of the
scholars in the which is quite quite
interesting they did say that this
prohibition of striking in the face they
said that this applies even in Warfare
okay yes which is kind of difficult to
understand because Allah says in the
Quran above the head above the neck
sorry yeah yeah yeah so they said this
yes because Allah created Adam in His
image and this so this is General
applying to absolutely everything so
this is one understanding yeah so
according to Al he said is a huge
mistake he does not agree with this
opinion at all and then he has CL
statements CU that would mean that you
can't you can't hit the guy you can't
hit in military Warfare you can't hit
his face that's what that opinion would
suggest yeah yeah that's what that's
exactly what that opinion is that even
in Warfare you cannot the face yeah
pause the video for a second you thought
I'd forget about you when you're
finished with the video make sure you
click the link below and put a donation
for the Masid and then he comes with the
Ayah that the day that these people will
be basically dragged on the fire on on
the faces so he's saying that uh meaning
non-muslims in this specific case people
who die in non-muslims and stuff so he's
saying and then he
said basic yeah hor so this means what
kind of sanctity is is it for so so his
opinion yes and again we are just
analyzing opinions not any doing any
nothing like this we're just studying
classical Islamic literature that's
we're talking about is this is this guy
living now or was he hundreds of years
ago yeah hundreds of years ago years ago
he died in 893 hij in fact wow okay so
it's a very classical okay not that
classical okay sure it's like 14 4 fine
fine you have more classical people of
course of course but the point is if
he's using this kind of an argument yes
that means he's making a general case
yes he's making a general case that he's
saying that this being applicable yeah
uh in the context of warfare is wrong
and then he's using this Ayah as well to
say that there is no for
the of someone who does not believe face
okay yeah sure
okay he's a obscure figure someone will
argue have you got any any of the heavy
weights any of the heavy weights some of
them uh mentioned for example that this
that you have it's not an of means
command imperative yeah command exactly
imperative command so you have this
right when you have
an or different kinds of things right
yeah even ex he
says yeah exactly exactly whatever no no
no you have this
thing the thing
of I used so so you have this kind of
con so some of them they did mention
that this H the in this is not for so
it's not obligatory it's for it's a
recommendation it's a recommendation so
if someone does it if someone does hit
the face yeah then according to this
view he's not committing he's not
committing a sin he's not committing a
sin yeah but still it's it's the
recommend to stay away from of course
who is that who says that for example he
mentioned that he that's a major scholar
of the Han isn't he yeah he's a scholar
from I'm going to have to
milk
sorry I'm mil him for his go
yeah but yeah but he he doesn't say it's
his opinion yes he's but he he is
portraying because it's like the only
opinion he's mentioning but he's still
saying usually it's it's weak it's not
really the because some Han listen to
say it's not the it's not the it's true
you you need to be honest you need to be
academic of course it's not this not the
is
not it's it's not in fact this opinion
it is a minority opinion because the
vast majority of Scholars who talked
about this they did mention that this is
in fact for sure sure and they had long
discussions like for example he had
discussions about
this they did have discuss about this
and the reason they had a discussion
about this is because of this because
this different opinion the also said
that it is for I I thought I saw
something
from bro have you got that because
that's a big figure in a and he's
written lots of on the Hadith and
including this Hadith I think so what's
his position on this matter H again his
position is not quite clear because he
says something very similar okay he quot
the you know meaning if you're fighting
with others if you're hitting others
and yeah and then he says after words
let me just find a quote again I flipped
the phone so you know what happened you
know
this
function basically he said yeah so he
says the same thing he
says he says the same thing
yeah there you have it so he's giving
though he's giving reasoning here isn't
he yeah he's giving a reasoning yeah
because the obvious matter and he's
talking about in this example he's
giving yeah in the context of warfare
is going to be I'm sorry is that it is
uh that he's going to fight not another
Muslim but he's going to fight a
non-muslim sure sure and then what's
also interesting is that a lot of these
Scholars who talked about this to some
of them they also mentioned the incident
in the time of the Prophet sallallah
wasallam yes that it was another Muslim
who was hearing another Muslim and it
was in this context that this was so
that's why we need to understand that
this Hadith or all this examples about
this Hadith is not just just about the
con context of warfare it's also about
generally speaking let's bring just one
more scholar just to make it something
else cuz he says these are all Fringe
opinions why you bring them together but
when you get one more opinion just to to
seal the deal here what are we talking
about have you got any other
names um you
have as well not no another one another
one yeah but he's still a bit Master
figure figure isn't he yeah from the
later lat yes yeah he's
saying been said that this is for right
that is this a recommendation yes and
then he also mentioned this thing that I
just talked
about hold on for a second you still
want those incredible rewards right so
make sure you click the link below and
you donate for the Mega Masjid project
subh so he mentioned this that in the
time of theet wasallam it was a person a
Muslim who's hitting another believer
and you know what's interesting bro it's
like you were mentioning before we
started this um this episode you
mentioned something which is actually
quite another opinion also should we do
that first what is the opinion yes the
other so this is a third opinion is very
similar to the other one though and this
is from another scholar
called yeah it's difficult to pronounce
the name he's
saying so he's saying that basically the
opposite of but if you do it it's notam
it's Mak he saying yeah and he's a Hani
as well so you have a chunk of Han
saying things like this now once again I
know the Han are going to say this not
the and we've asked the MU and he's
going to say of the and so but in a
sense that's not a discussion
I'm you have and I respect the Han a lot
even though I'm not myself yeah I really
do I really respect them I do respect
the but personally though I don't agree
with this concept obligatory to follow
the of a and that's more of an
discussion that maybe we'll open up
another kind of you have both opinions
exist I respect both opinions yes but
personally I don't think that is the so
the thing is um going back to the issue
of Brotherhood on this idea of being
um the the word here it's seen in other
Hadith okay now obviously someone could
say thean but that's very very their
brother their brothers their brothers
whatever their brothers such and such
prophets mentioned for for example but
that's you can see the context is very
spec specific their brothers their
country brother yeah they're living in
within but or in the third person when
or second person when the prophet is
doing it it doesn't usually
come in the as a as a non-muslim
Brotherhood in it's talking about
Brotherhood in Islam so for example give
you one
example the B standard definition that
the prophet wasam gave of what is what
is backbiting he
said mentioning about your brother what
he doesn't like so most Scholars say
that I mean this is a controversial
thing to say but backbiting where you
actually get major sins doesn't apply
with f and it doesn't apply with kuf it
doesn't that's what the the majority of
Scholars say yeah Muslims so it doesn't
apply with fics Muslims who are known to
do certain things it doesn't apply with
disbelievers that's what or non-muslims
so the H of backbiting you could say you
got s similar phraseology here with the
brother in this Hadith and the brother
in this Hadith so you can see where
they're coming from I mean it's not it's
not yeah that's the whole thing you can
see you can see like even the the you
can say generally speaking yes even
though as I mentioned this they said
this is is brother it applies to the
Brotherhood regarding meaning from Adam
the Brotherhood of humanity that this is
what this is talking about so you can't
argue in this way as well you generally
speaking it's true like if you take the
how if you look at the the text textual
evidences of the when you when you have
the word your brother mentioned
there or anything like and it's
unqualified yeah yeah it is unqualified
but usually it does refer to the Muslim
brother Muslim sister
speaking that is what is the case yes
it's true so I mean it makes perfect
sense what I was going to say about this
is that look we're not making a feta
therefore cuz the conclusion someone can
bring is well therefore this is that
means you're you're going to do the
thing now the conclusion someone can
bring is that therefore
M or even even boxing going into boxing
matches or kickboxing multi everything
and and frankly what to be clear you're
not making a fatwa here on any of that
stuff you're not making on that you're
not saying because let me tell you how
it works I mean as I'm sure you know
right no tell me no no no but frankly
there's gradations of it so someone can
do uh for example sparring in a club and
that sparring in a club is you're not
trying to hurt the other person you you
can do Tech we call technical sparring
yeah and you will end up hitting the
face you hit no no you hit the face with
the gloves and you can get him back and
it's whatever but you're not trying to
knock him out you're not that will be
seen as bad manners in the club if
you're if you're doing that some of the
this would be Haram if you take a l
literalist reading and implementation of
this Hadith this would
the face you've got the hard sping level
up you've got like you know inter Club
fights or whatever you level up you've
got amateur fights and then you have uh
professional fights now if we all of
these things they're all separate fetas
for separate people in separate
circumstances some people bro they
coming off the streets and they've got
high dopamine energy yeah and let's say
they've been told to go and do and I do
believe that Freestyle Wrestling is
probably the best one anyway right and
it doesn't require any hitting in the
face it's like if you know how to really
freestyle wrestling whatever but they
want to feel a little bit of passion
they want to feel a little bit of fear
whatever those people get them off the
streets for example and into a boxing
ring or get them into a kickboxing ring
it may be the lesser of two evils for
some people but that would require fatwa
to be passed on that person he's coming
out of the life of crime and gangsters
and you tell him you have to do this and
that it might be difficult for him
people are suffering from addictions so
these are outlets at least we should
know as the Muslim Community that there
are other opin on this very Hadith now
the mutis is their job now to do the
implementation on specific circumstances
everyone knows their situation best they
go to a Muti they say this and that calm
down calm down calm down it's just a
break I'm reminding you that when you
are finished watching the video H that
you click the link below and donate now
but at least the and the students of
knowledge in the MU should be aware of
these so that they can start applying
the tools of if and when necessary and
possible do you think this is a fair
enough assessment
yeah I I completely agree with
everything mention now alhamdulillah so
the the thing is this evidence in of
itself a there right but because you
have the classical Scholars that did
differ in how to apply it back then so
that means that today if you want to
look at all these different kinds of
martial arts they have which involved
striking in the face and this and that
um it is true that a lot of them they
did use this Hadith right they based it
upon this Hadith but the thing is um
this this Hadith is understood by the
classical scholars in different ways for
example does apply to the to the
non-muslims you talked about is the
command of of obligation or is it just
like a recommendation so because of this
we're not saying that MMA for example if
you're going to UFC that's Halal we're
not saying that we're not going to give
such a fwa like this because there might
be other reasons other factors other
things that like for example the issue
of right you have problems like this you
have other kinds of issues ring girls
this and that alcohol yeah all these
different things
you cannot give a about this like to
make something like this is completely
what I'm trying to say is that this
specific yes and then to say to use this
which is frankly they only the like as a
nus that's used yeah as a nus that's
what we see this is a you have some
similar things also but this is the main
thing this is the thing right to say
that this in of itself is enough to make
all s of striking in the face as Haram
and to the extent that this is to the
extent this is to to the extent that
this this agreed upon and this CLE this
is something I don't think is the case
at all I don't think this dis because
you have the classical Scholars who
opened up some room for itad about these
specific matters here so that's what we
need to think so I think basically my
what I believe is you need to assess
each martial arts even the aspect of
striking in the face it needs to be
assessed according to uh the the rules
of of that specific martial arts to
which extent if they're going like like
how brutal how
BR for example be luck on boxing that
might be like come on like you know
these guys have nothing you break your
wrist on the guys comes out because at
the end of they also have the aspect of
right of
harm you can see every time someone does
something like that they're losing a
massive part of their health anyway yeah
exactly and we have to think about CTE
and all this brain damage and all that
stuff which is new technology which
actually is is there as well but then
that's what I'm saying we have we're
just opening the door on this issue
because it's every situation is is
different and um it's thank you so much
for this I think it's been very very
pleasurable honestly I think a lot of
people it's the first time someone of
knowledge I think has actually spoken
about this in this way in the western
world or even in the arabic speaking
world because it just I don't think
anyone has had the
motivation or maybe the courage to to
mention this difference of opinion but
I'm here with zishan and she zishan here
works with Islam n he's an unbelievable
researcher fantastic he because he's
able to go like a wizard on
this he's actually taught me how to use
it to some extent although there's some
lessons to be learned which is a
fantastic database probably the biggest
one we you say now the Muslim world
where you can look at all the scholarly
opinions there's about 10,000 books on
there I think in general and we we
looked at all the books and stuff like
that we were able to bring you this kind
of information today and that's why we
always need as a backbone of our work
people like researchers like
shishan and of course you know what I'm
going to do now isn't it I'm going to
tell you that you're not just investing
in bricks and water you're investing in
people and power when you work when you
invest in the Islamic daa uh in Islamic
dawa of course but the Islam net project
you got the link below when you click
that link you're going to be helping
expand this Masjid there's other masjids
that we're getting a uh properties and
stuff like that which then fund this
organization there's the Muslim civil
rights arm of this organization which
has been doing the best work here in
Scandinavia we have the Islamic Research
we have the daa it's the best bang for
your buck you have to click the link
below and donate
[Music]
now